honestly this entire thing has felt like
a dream maybe we're just the desert
string this what happens when you go in
the desert you get weird I want to think
about the desert I just think hot why
would you want to go to the desert the
desert is a place where there's no water
I am excited about going to the desert I
just don't want the Sun to touch my body
the construction that's outside of my
window the traffic on the 405 I'm ready
to take a break from that and be
somewhere new I was thinking about it I
was like oh we're gonna go to the desert
I'm gonna get to see camels as like
wrong continents
that's it
oh wait there's like the like
civilization over here you saying coyote
what just cool cool I really don't want
to see any critters but I do want to see
critter absolutely there's a door I love
that somebody put this here what if we
get sucked into a vortex and never come
back there's so much more life out here
than I thought it would be like you can
feel it and welcome to your first
experience going through sound you're
gonna notice your body your mind and
your heart reacting to it very very
differently and then emotionally you may
notice but desire I need to weep or cry
why are you guys just taking it slow
deep breaths into the nose just enjoy
the right
[Music]
[Music]
I had so many visual stuff going into
childhood to travels to like certain
emotions that are attached to certain
colors what about you Kirk
I got a P and it's like I'm just
listening to someone's weird sound
experiment my brain has a big barrier
against like meditation or spiritual
growth hydrate or die drains good advice
we're out here desert here's everybody
from here it's feels so nice I want to
bring this stillness and just carry that
with me when I need it I want to bring
back the weirdness of course I mean I
like just the vastness of everything in
LA you could only see one block here
we're seeing into forever I've read
somewhere that you have to find the
climate that you belong in and that's
where you can fries I knew going in the
deserts not my location but I had to go
experience it still and all that means
is I just got to keep like journeying
and you know the adventure continues
[Music]